i believe marketing should influence 100
of the pipeline all the time
and if you're not doing that you're not
doing marketing correctly to begin with
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
marketing is crucial and today i'm going
to learn just how much
meet kai lacey chief marketing officer
of lessonly
kyle brings over 14 years of experience
in marketing with a slice of revenue
he is currently chief marketing officer
at lesson league and prior to joining
lesson league kyle held senior positions
at openview salesforce and exact target
he is also the author of three books
twitter marketing for dummies branding
yourself and social crm for dummies he
wears monotone
loves history and hates onions meet kyle
kai lacey welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm good thank you for having me i think
this might be the first time that i
get a chance to speak to somebody who
held the title of chief mario officer
uh so now it's a chief marketing officer
at lesson league but but your journey
spans well beyond just uh marketing
uh with with various different
organizations that you've been a part of
including salesforce including
a quite a few years in venture capital
and now
you're building an amazing team within
lesson league you've seen the team grow
just by with them within the marketing
from 10 to 40 you mentioned the company
from 50 to 250
and and you know i'm excited to pick
your brain both on
your experience within lessonly but also
how that draws to a greater trend and
pattern
within you know the high tech ecosystem
and specifically the marketing domain
and so before we get to all that kyle
who who are you in an essence you've
done so many different things throughout
your career
how would you define your own career in
your eyes
i mean i i fundamentally i'm a marketer
for sure and i just happen to go
from being a brand marketer to being a
brand marketer that
is is measured on revenue and that's
something that
i talk about quite a bit on why
marketing should be comped off revenue
creation instead of it just being
like a pipeline influence but for me
it's a
it's i'd say it's a creative marketing
that drives
revenue is kind of where i focus as a
leader
now what is what is the alternative that
you mentioned
so marketing for brand and how how do
you actually
you know measure that and why are those
two things you know
alternatives to each other i think a lot
of times
in my past lives i've seen marketing
teams that go off
of of an influence number like we we did
x amount of activities and we
influenced x amount of revenue or
pipeline meaning
that there was a touch point at some
point in the sales cycle that marketing
was a part of
and lessenly it's more around direct
sourcing
meetings that then lead to revenue and
it's not necessarily like i believe
marketing should influence 100 of the
pipeline all the time
and if you're not doing that you're not
doing marketing correctly to begin with
so for us it's pipeline generated and
revenue generated
and that's how the teams are measured
and it actually helps with alignment on
sales because sales and marketing own
the same number
so so talk to me a little bit about
lessonly both what the company does but
then how the organization is structured
to do
exactly what you just mentioned which is
the marketing towards revenue
yeah so so leslie's training and
enablement software for sales and
customer service teams
headquartered in indianapolis indiana
like you said about
250 employees you know more remote now
than we were before the pandemic of
course but um
you know leslie's structured a little
bit differently than most
orgs our revenue teams our
services cx
marketing and sales those teams are
responsible for generating revenue
but what's interesting is that we have
what's called a revenue effectiveness
team
and a revenue ops team that lives
lives in the they're basically the hub
of the go to market model for lesson
league
so all of the information that all the
teams need to know
and all the data that all the revenue
teams need to know are centralized in
one
in one place so it has allowed us as a
company
to scale appropriately because we have
centralized our funnel
our definitions are enablement like if a
persona changes it's really easy to
enable everybody
and product marketing also lives in
revenue effectiveness it doesn't live in
marketing
the other thing is that all of our
outbound bdrs and sdrs
live in marketing so it actually
encourages alignment between sales and
marketing because a lot of the
meetings that the aes need to
need in order to hit quota come from
marketing so you have to work closely
together
it doesn't work now when we're talking
about this
you know it and i understand this this
is different than most companies this
and this is different than most
organizational structures and companies
but why is that because
you know what you're what you're telling
me sounds very convincing and soon we're
also going to raise the question
of you know uh b2b versus you know b2c
and then strategy behind yeah but
but why why is lessonly different and
why do you have this strong conviction
that this is the right thing for you i
mean
it's dif we just kind of do what we feel
is right in the org structure and
there's not really
um i wouldn't say there's necessarily a
playbook that we're following it's it's
whatever
feels like the correct thing to do and
not like going back and saying oh what
did x amount of companies do out of our
portfolio or whatever
um for for us it's what makes the most
sense with
the current team that we have and what
helps us grow
faster right and so
b2b should copy b2c
when you when you think through that
statement what does that actually mean
you know tangibly that's a pretty loaded
statement
well yeah outside of just consumer
marketing is more creative and better
i mean i i uh
we can talk all day long and and i'd be
interested in what you think about this
from the engineering side but i
i don't ever think features are a
competitive advantage
um you you launch a feature it's going
to get built by your competitors it
doesn't matter
the only thing that's a competitive
advantage is brand and experience
right and so the best marketers at brand
and experience are consumer marketers
because they have to be because there's
too many choices like
the the marketing lead for burger king
has
like the total addressable market for
burger king and all the competitors is
freaking ridiculous like it's
it's it's terrible and so you have to be
so experience driven in order to win
and i and i think that the software
companies that have won markets
are the ones that have understood that
you've got to build a great product
but your experience has to be better
than
the competition and that includes brand
that includes pre-sales includes post
sales like the entire journey
and i just think consumer marketers are
better at it and so if
you know as a young entrepreneur let's
say that myself and my friends want to
enter into a b2b sas company right
we want to start something of that sort
and we have to think strategically
through
we know where we're putting our eggs and
where we're you know
investing our time and effort and so
when you think through
you know that rationale what is it
actually what are the implications for
that
for a young entrepreneur that is now
starting their journey
i think a lot of i think that one of the
larger mistakes that entrepreneurs make
is they don't hire a great designer
up front and that could be that could be
a
graphic designer for for your go to
market strategy or it could be ux ui
um you got to get that right first in my
opinion
so you know whether it's i also think
hiring product marketer early
there's a couple roles that i think you
should hire early
product marketing enablement and a great
designer
and you know it's really dependent on
the product it depends on your get like
are you product led are you sales led
i still think what's interesting about
having a great designer
is that it doesn't matter if you're a
product leader sales led model
you you still have to have great design
in my opinion
um the companies that i think are going
to win like the
the um wherebys of the world
right that are competing with zoom if
you look at their design
it is just immaculate and they got that
they got that right at the beginning it
was you know so i
i just think that hiring a great
designer pays back
tenfold if you do it correctly
right no i i think that makes a lot of
sense and you know i i i've been
wondering for quite some time when i'm
looking at a lot of early stage startups
you know why they're choosing to have
you know seven eight people on their r d
team you know from the get-go without
product marketing without any designing
figure
and when you know at the end the
messaging is just as important as the
technology itself if you don't have
you know if you don't explain the
product well then nobody's going to want
to use your product and
and there's always the anomalies but
yeah makes perfect sense
kyle from you you've come into this role
and i'll take the role of chief
mario officer because it's more fun to
say and you've coming
you know you've entered lesson league
both at a really interesting time where
lesson league is obviously growing
uh tremendously and you're building the
strategy behind the marketing and you're
watching it grow
you're bringing with you a lot of
experience
i i'd love for you to touch on some
parts of your career and the different
experiences whether they be in venture
capital in salesforce
and in the different organizations um
what what do you take with you now that
you look back
maybe you didn't do marketing before but
now you're saying wow like i'm really
glad i had this experience because it
taught me something
um being being an entrepreneur before i
joined like exact target which was my
first software role
i i had to learn i had to learn the
balance between
ego and empathy and that especially was
um
was important for me at exact target
because i
it was the first team that i built that
was pretty high growth i mean we had a
content marketing team of i think 15
people
so and then i learned that i learned
even that even deeper
lesson the the how how are you
how do you check your ego how do you
make sure you're being proactive
as much as possible and aggressive but
also empathetic to the needs of the team
and also empathetic to the to the needs
of you know are they balancing time
appropriately mental health like
so i you know if you if there's anything
for entrepreneurs and vcs and people who
are investing in high growth startups to
think about
it's how do you make sure you're scaling
and doing hyper growth
without just killing people i mean and
that's
i think that's uh that is a really
really hard
thing to balance and it's something over
the course of my career i've had to
learn
especially last year 2020 where
you know we had the majority of people
in one office
and then everybody went remote and
you have to like i had 30 plus people
and you had to understand where each of
them were at from a mental standpoint
just because of everything happening of
course in
you know outside just the pandemic
everything happening in the united
states right so
um that's probably it the other thing is
making sure you understand when an
inflection point
in your career is happening um i think a
lot of times
uh entrepreneurs entrepreneurs are
better at understanding this but people
who are working at startups you get
antsy
and you want to leave because you see
better opportunities but you need to
understand when
you are just getting bored and you need
to be challenged or you're ready to
leave
it's very very important to because if
you
if you decide that every time you're
bored you're going to leave a company
you're never going to get the experience
that you need when it comes to failing
when it comes to being
challenged when it comes to being
stressed like all the stuff that you
learn if you stick through it
i see a lot of times people just don't
stick through it they see the next great
opportunity and they go do it
and they don't understand that where you
excel
and where you will find that next big
thing is when you fail
and you're challenged right marketing
leadership
and one of the things that i love
talking most here is about you know this
leadership and this idea that leadership
you know
comes and comes into play in different
domains and different
stages and and and you know i i'd love
to learn a little bit more about what it
means to be
a leader in the marketing domain so
growing the team
to now 40 right and
what does that actually mean for you
what do you have to do in order to do
that from 10 to 40
whether it means an aligning of the
vision you're talking about you know the
pandemic and everything that happened in
the u.s
and all of a sudden you know if before
you were guiding the vision of the
marketing now you're also guiding people
how
how does that balance out
uh i so when i when i first joined
lesson league about half my time was
tactical
like i was doing like very granular
doing stuff
now it's about making sure that
everybody is taken care of
and and i'm looking 12 to
18 months in advance my team's looking
you know three to six months in advance
but
like i i don't do anything tactical
anymore
really i mean i like other than like
high level projects
exec team projects that were sponsoring
for me
it's making sure my team has what they
need to do what they what they love
and um making sure people are aligned
i mean that's it before with 10 people
all in one office you know you just
looked at people and talked to them but
now
like especially as we start yeah as we
start and you know this as we start
going more
global and and we start thinking about
what happens when we go to apac or uk
or south america like what there's just
it's more strategy than it is anything
else so it's taking care of the team
making sure they have what they need in
order to do what they love
not just to do crap every day and then
you know sit i do a lot of meetings i
sit in a lot of meetings
so you know i obviously you know we we
want to have a handle on on the people
we manage
and and i'm looking forward to the
opportunity that i'll have hopefully one
day doing the same thing
but when it comes to reality it's not as
easy it's not as trivial and people
don't necessarily especially remote they
don't necessarily want to come out and
say i'm not feeling good right
and and so there's a lot of different
pla things that pull you in different
directions
how do you then you know hold either
yourself accountable or
you know the organization accountable
for making sure that you do have that
strong grasp because i think that's
really just
it's not a trivial thing to do
yeah so so from a company standpoint we
have a quarterly survey that's anonymous
that goes out
so we so we have a good two or three
years of data to see
like what where the mental mindset is
from from a marketing perspective
i the the best thing two best things
that i've done
i am very open with my team on when i am
depressed when i'm not happy when i need
to give them
space when you're a leader and you can
say guys
i'm taking half day because i'm just not
in a good spot
they feel like they have the ability to
do that and the other one is
i have every quarter i meet with each
team member
for 30 minutes now
that was easier with 10 people now with
43 45 people
that's hard however it gives them the
ability to
to connect with me and ask questions and
make sure that
i understand where they think there's
opportunities for improvement
and that you know sometimes that gleans
information but with all
three of those things it works pretty
well
did your over four years in venture
capital
what impact did it have on on the rest
of your trajectory whether it's
the ability to see things more broadly
or horizontally or diving deep and
giving feedback
what was that experience like for you uh
venture capital for me was getting a
master's
in in software like actually truly
understanding what it takes to grow a
company because when you join
when i joined exact target we hired 500
people that year
like there wasn't like a primer on
growth it was this was a rocket ship
already
uh the other thing is network like i
i the best going to open view
was an amazing decision not just because
me understanding software but my i grew
my network
pretty exponentially and uh
i it has been a huge influence in my
in my career after so those are the two
those are the two things the most
important things
amazing kyle i really want to thank you
for coming in and i appreciate
you know the honesty and the
transparency and i and i have a few
questions not about marketing or about
uh lesson lead but i have a few
questions about kyle if you're ready
yeah i'm ready and we'll we'll go back
all the way to a middle school or high
school i'm curious to know what
what's a what's your favorite subject
from during that time
uh history military history i'm obsessed
with
civil war and world war ii world war one
geopolitics
in that time frame in those time frames
and i why
military history
when i was little we every time we went
to rent
vhs tapes from the grocery store i
always got the
the movie gettysburg so
so from six years old on i was
constantly watching this terrible movie
called gettysburg about the battle of
gettysburg in the civil war
and since then i've just i i'm obsessed
with history in general
i think it's i think it's amazing to
read about but i prefer
more of the geopolitical stuff that has
to do with the civil
not as much as civil war but definitely
world war ii
wow and who would serve as a role model
of yours or somebody that inspires you
in some way shape or form um
scott dorsey is probably so scott dorsey
was ceo of exact target he's on the
board at lesson league
pretty much every career decision i've
made since 2012
has to do with him so really
yeah so i well there's there's a really
long story that has to do with that he
helped me out
when he should like i was a 25 year old
kid and he took the time to help me and
since then
you know it's just i'm trying to pay him
back for that
over the last you know 12 years 14 years
um
so yeah he's he's it the way that he
leads
the way that he invests in his community
he's just a great human being
amazing and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um i'd say
empathetic proactive
and this this kind of contradicts but i
i'm i'm pretty proactive and aggressive
but i'm also laid back
so i'm not as like i'm crazy
the the contradictions are always the
best kyle thank you so much for
for being here i know how busy you are i
really appreciate it and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
yeah thank you
good to see you
[Music]
you